[Musique]
c'est la deuxième ville des Pays-Bas
moins connue moins visité qu'Amsterdam
mais qui se développe de manière
spectaculaire
une ville complètement détruite durant
la Deuxième Guerre mondiale
progressivement reconstruite selon des
standards modernes
Rotterdam compte 600 000 habitants et sa
population s'accroît de 5 à 6000
personnes par année sur un territoire
très
restreintes ont quitté leur maison de
banlieue il y a un peu plus d'un an pour
venir vivre ici en plein centre-ville
dans une sorte de petit village qui
compte une quinzaine de tours de
différentes hauteurs
[Musique]
les tours sont reliés par des
passerelles les groupées trois par trois
avec une terrasse par groupe sur les
toits
[Musique]
le but de projet se connecter le centre
de ville et le vieux quartier pour ça
nous avons construit beaucoup des allées
et petits places toutes les projets sur
un hectares nous avons
320 appartements
aussi oui 1000 mètres carrés de bureau
et encore de petits cafés des ateliers
et tous ensemble pour ça c'est vivant
pour le vice social c'est important de
faire mixture tout le monde qui veut
venir ici sont bienvenus donc vous avez
intégré le concept du commerce dans
l'espace résidentiel oui je pense c'est
très important aussi de faire une
connexion spacieux
est-ce que les gens qui habitent là-bas
viennent ici ah oui bien sûr donc ça
marche ça marche tout le projet est bâti
au dessus du sol et pourtant il y a de
la végétation partout c'est une des
grandes caractéristiques de la
densification à Rotterdam l'aménagement
d'espace vert et en particulier de
toiles
Paul Van russmann est le grand manitou
des toits verts à rotterdames
il y a sous le sol un système de capture
et de rétention d'eau qui permet
d'alimenter les plantes même par période
de grande sécheresses
[Musique]
provenant de la ville mais aussi du
gouvernement néerlandais et même de
l'Union européenne sont disponibles pour
verdir les toits anciens et nouveaux
autre particularité de la densification
néerlandaise la promotion de mode de
transport écologique
[Musique]
l'urbaniste en chef de Rotterdam c'est
lui il est au centre de la politique de
densification et de revitalisation de la
ville
space
les premiers programmes de densification
de Rotterdam visite à attirer une
clientèle aisée dans des appartement
luxueux aujourd'hui on est dans
l'approche inverse chaque nouveau projet
doit comporter au moins 20% de logements
sociaux et une bonne moitié de logement
abordable
la politique de densification a
Rotterdam est conçu pour faire face aux
défis posé par les changements
climatiques reste à voir jusqu'où on
peut aller dans cette voie sans empiéter
sur la sécurité et la vie privée Billy